[Music]
here okay awesome I nobody cares and
start the new year off right with
PlayStation Network is down
Just Cause 3 can't get it to work we're
gonna play then gauntlet with you guys
with fans place there's no reason so
we're gonna play a local game of
gauntlet and we're gonna have a good
time
we got the enough famous on the internet
t-shirt either how was your news really
great can't argue with that a snowman a
creeper in the corner let's see it hey
2016 everybody
McGee what's up oh there's no sound
there's no sound there is sound alright
now it's so hot it's so hot hey captain
quasar what's up Macca boards game vol I
God what's going on no one knows guys
it's 2016 we're still all drunk we're
still all super girly and by us still
we're all drunk I mean I currently am
drunk right now
alright we're constructing - going
alright here we go now I you for those
of you guys you've never played gauntlet
before do you know what a gauntlet is
I've heard I remember the gauntlet on
MTV after like the real world real
world/road rules gauntly you say that
real world that's tough this game is not
based on that this game is a classic 80s
arcade game so mate tech gremlins I know
somebody Trek : so that was you just
said that this game is based on an old
80's game where you play one of four
characters okay you can play the wizard
you can play the elf the neck
necromancer is not in the old one
warrior or Valkyrie I'm gonna go
Valkyrie
but yeah ellcrys and then you wander
around a maze in a dungeon and you just
kill everything alright that's gonna be
great so we're gonna start we've invited
some people from the show last minute to
come play with us
I don't know if they're gonna come play
with us so this might be the saddest
gauntlet ever yeah just one part this
game is all about teamwork it's all
about banding together
and it is just me just me alone so
here's a fun story you guys want to hear
a fun story about New Year's what's here
a fun year sir they don't save this fun
to your story maybe I'll save it I'm
gonna save it for a while oh look at how
sad this is just lonely little Blaire
hey everybody I'm gonna kill something
that's right
no Ryota what's up flame beacon that's
right
oh yes flame beacon that's why I
downloaded this if you have PlayStation
Plus you're [ __ ] out of luck because the
PlayStation network's down but if you
have PlayStation Plus you can get you
can get this game for free which is why
i download it welcome i'm iraq here's
the thing characters in these games
always have names like more AK it's ever
like Carl
hello I'm Carl find the three lost
shards of tear fing and bring them to me
Carl and I will grant and Carl will
grant you power and riches
Morag we're exited dick it's free right
now pieces of tofu if you join if you if
you're a PlayStation Plus member by the
way if when I buy a house I'm this is my
front door right here it's gonna be a
giant mouth except that's gonna be your
face it's gonna be like Bert it's gonna
be like this come into my house yeah
yeah it's pretty great right my t-shirt
says not famous on the internet either
which is true
Beth what do you think tombs of the
risen perhaps teams of the kitchen
that's that's how bad Beth is it cooking
she sees tombs of the kitchen oh yeah
that's right Seinfeld we brought Thank
You captain quasar thank you by the way
if you haven't seen the new Seinfeld
comedians in cars getting coffee Obama
it's awesome that's right that's right
actually have a funny story
if you one of you guys follow me on
instagram which you should Aaron Blair
as follow Team Coco all
so but here's a funny little story that
involves what are the Obama's are you
ready we went and met the first lady
Michelle Obama and we went to Qatar and
we taped a show which I don't know when
it's gonna air but kind of mentioned
this on the air so I'm not telling any
new information
Aaron soonish all right so here's let me
just if you'll indulge me for a second
as you don't follow me on Instagram
here's what happened so we got to meet
the first lady she's incredible and
amazing inspirational unbelievable and
everything you would hope for it's
amazing
here's what happened okay we meet the
first lady regretting we get a great
photo first lady and I I don't know if
you can see this meet the first lady oh
wait you know what I'm gonna show you
this photo here I'm gonna show you a
different photo here hold on let me see
oh this is gonna take forever
okay she put in the link at the end of
the day I realized after we met the
first lady all that stuff I looked down
and my I missed button my shirt so the
only time I got a photo with the first
lady my frickin shirt I missed a button
if you go to like go to the link that
Beth put up what's wrong with me I mean
seriously look I have I'm dumb
I'm so that was you know it's not like
I'm sure that'll happen again me meeting
the first lady getting a photo with her
so messed that one up pretty bad Oh a
pic fail man FML for sure just good lord
I don't know sometimes how why I get out
of bed and by the way or or how I get
out of bed I don't really understand how
gravity works it's kind of complicated
kind of complex but I've never met the
president I have miss Beth so let's just
shove Aaron off the screen and talk to
only Beth Beth why don't you talk tell
us about Boston how was it
opossums great teen umbrella is just
because I wanted
Wow that's never won laughing I got you
well you learned your lesson like a Jane
Austen character but I didn't die after
they're always good nothing there's
nothing Jane Austen about that no they
always go in the rain for work really is
that what happened how do I let me just
slice it through these dudes yeah that's
true by the way
good point good point but the other
thing too is at the end of the day
here's what I was thinking so I look
down right and I'm like oh my shirts
buttoned wrong I'm so upset but then I
was like wait a second in the picture
did I pose like this that I yeah exactly
right there you can see miss by much
you can see aah oh yeah get in there I
was like oh did I pose like this or did
I pose like this and I posed with my
hands behind my back hair
so there you go yeah there we go let's
go through yeah it's a quick tip see
here's the thing I put the extra button
I put the extra button where the button
hole is don't if you make shirts don't
put the extra button on the shirt give
it to the people in a nice little bags
or else this could happen I don't I'm
saying it's ridiculous it's ridiculous
anyway so that no there we go oh yeah
you're circling it oh yeah you can take
it down take it down it's terrible
but anyway also just to cover yourself
guys and ladies we posed with someone
who you don't know if you're ever gonna
meet them ever again go hands in front
yeah if you know if you're just if you
have a choice you have a choice just to
cover yourself that covers everything
covers it covers everything but yeah I
was an amazing trip and yeah I hope you
guys could see it soon
great killed by the way though I will
say on my phone where's my phone on my
phone currently on my phone oh god
there's so many I get so many
notifications man that's my phone right
there it's the button that's my that's
the back of my phone right there so
there you go just to remind me that I'm
an idiot always which is like I need
reminding so guys here's the problem
with just cause we can't lock it it
won't let us play offline mode on Just
Cause 3 so we had to call an audible and
play gauntlet which we're playing
offline mode that's also why we're not
playing with you guys which kind of
stinks because so sorry about that but
if the place the PlayStation why are you
doing maintenance all day today you guys
are out of Monday really what are we
doing
what are you what are you doing guys
someone asked what is the password to
your phone it's a finger thing it's I'd
have to draw it it's basically it's just
a giant penis
cuz I'm 13 so now you guys know nothing
will stand in the way of vengeance
except all these guys will be this
little she'll throw thing is great by
the way is Mike Sweeney taller than
Conan oh good question
oooh same height they're both tall I
think they're both 6 4 I'm six threes
they're both tower over me by an inch
Conan's already come down to my desk
once today and frightened me ooh there
we go get that turkey yo that delicious
turkey wait I don't know if I want to go
this way I want to go back this way get
some treasure Beth this game is all
about treasure just like real life
should only care about them ducats and
making that money is that what people
say yeah exactly
now what did you guys all do chat what
did you guys all do for the new year how
was your New Year's because I have a
great new year story for you that's
gonna make you both weep and laugh
probably yes fans have ruined everything
basically any fan I I saw Star Wars is
great fun times
oh those guys you blow up move that
sucked
dead how do I come back how do I come
back and can I come back as many times
as I want how does this game work horses
fun in your sleep my least favourite
holiday by the way it's the worst
there's just no good it's just you have
to be having fun at a very specific time
I'm not a fan I'm not a friend oh
brother Todd help get raised problem
neighbors evicted wow that's a good news
starting the new years off right also
here's the thing is like people who make
these like New Year's Eve resolute news
resolutions oh my god this is Jesus you
could change your life every oh man this
is bad what's about to happen you don't
want them to surround you I think
Jesus God I'm back
can I use potions
I think I got to use sorry yeah this is
exactly Carrie Potter world is it Snape
is in all of us I hate those things
this is on ps4 it's free by the way if
you are a PlayStation member of course
it's not free now because they're doing
maintenance so you are Sol they do
maintenance like Sony doesn't do their
own got it well that seems like a good
idea right Sony I mean you know a tiny
little mom-and-pop company like Sony
doesn't have the resources to do their
own maintenance I get it Snape was in me
last night
I don't get it oh yeah that's true right
you mean like I had sex with Snape yeah
okay fair enough what if this is how you
guys find out I have like a Snape life
doll which I'm sure they say they
definitely have some kind of weird Snape
sex doll right let's see here
she cut them up so your boomerang can
get them on the way back
what does kite the mob's me
Jesus
Nate sexually entered bleh
plain Just Cause 3 when the PlayStation
never gets back up that's one
there we go oh that's great way I can
use the blow-up guys to kill the other
dudes damn it
ah the worst and we're back
whoo I'm a Captain America with this
thing it's very zoomed out yeah they're
supposed to be more than just one person
playing by the way yes
I was I wanted to play with you guys
with this game but it didn't happen
Jesus God I'm getting just destroyed so
boring just died and revived yeah I know
sorry
I joined snapchat over the break that
was the big thing I did it's very fun of
you guys I have a sweet Jordan shlonsky
snapchat I made today it's amazing I
told him I wouldn't show it but maybe I
should just show by georgia shlonsky
snapchat you guys want to see my
journeys landing and you know an
exclusive if you follow me on snapchat I
got a lot of good shatters going on a
lot of it snaps ooh I feel like this is
a pretty this place probably smells
pretty bad don't you think it's kind of
musty and gross it's going out with that
it kind of looks like we're small loose
yeah it kind of looks very smug II got a
little crown though look at this little
crown I got I didn't know you know I
like the fact that you know gauntlet is
also about fashion yeah you know I mean
it's a lot of like killing guys but it's
also really fashionable yeah it's kind
of like a bow like Oh what kind of
accessories you got there you know yes a
lot of good leads no wait hold on first
of all here we go here we go here we go
wait I'm gonna how do I look up the
snapchat oh now we're moving on to the
catacombs
on occasion of the catacombs here we go
wait a second how do I look at my story
here I'm still learning now here we go
here we go all right I'm gonna turn this
up I'm gonna start over at the beginning
here all right you ready and here it
comes
you got your slansky over there let it
repeat how do I make this also look at a
creeper is one more time all right
anyway that's the kind of quality snaps
you can expect from old bleh it's just
Erin Blair yeah it used to be mouth
toilet but then I was like I should grow
up just make my name my name so just my
name airy blue quality snaps guys can
expect a little black
Oh God ah what's this yeah it does well
I'm just gonna run from this guy right I
don't have to kill all these dudes do I
oh boy that's a lot of dudes oh man wait
a second how come the bad guys don't die
from death oh Jesus
this is bad it's a little unfair I think
oh wait I just came up with a good
strategy throw my shield at these mofos
let's go it's not fair
how could this be fair there's like a I
got an unkillable creature
[Music]
unfair unfair not fair not fair
not fair not fair not fair this is
incredibly not cool get the blow-up you
guy instead of calling this game
gauntlet they should have called that
running circles while people chase you I
know it's not as cool of a name but
Oh F F this dude
he just like swims around basically
great
hi
run away I can't read the chat and run
from death
get them all together get them all
together
Jesus God
instead of Monday mail here they should
call it Aaron complains ease look guys
it's a new year I got a lot of stuff
going on oh this is great by the way
here's my New Year's Eve story alright
so this is great New Year's Eve but
hanging out with this girl a lot before
and put premiers Eve news even go back
to her place she and and like right
after midnight she's like I think I just
want to be friends I got friend-zoned
like five minutes into the New Year five
minutes it was crazy
Jesus God way to start off the new year
on a great foot there's so many bad guys
[Music]
I need to hit that guy with the thing
you know
just oh yeah
you know maybe this is this guy's like
terrible odor do you think about that
you know maybe it's just like that's it
just yeah just smells really bad
yeah my sister is awesome she got me a
virginity rock shirt there you go
she thinks it's hilarious that I get
friendzone right after midnight I see
I'm just getting the go baby
Beth what are some people saying in the
chat because it's hard for me to read
the chat and kill off a thousand people
at once I mean kind of be you're being
paid to be here Oh give me out here no
Josh damn it we're Legends what does
that mean I don't want to be a legend
that means I'm dead oh that was a great
kill YouTube chats asking if we've heard
of the dirty talk about that he's a Sith
yeah I don't understand I think that's
just something that people like talking
about I don't see any worth the evidence
what that old the CGI Andy Serkis guy is
supposed to be maybe know what that's
impossible
that was like some goofy theory that's
not true he's Darth Plagueis plagiarists
or whatever
- platypus that's his dark platypus okay
this is great
we can be living legends that's not true
you can't be a living legend okay so
people say no Star Wars spoilers I feel
like people should have seen it by now
right
Wow let's show you're right I think it's
it's you're well within the area of
people it's hard Oh got him I'm not sure
that that people can really get angry
now for Star Wars spoilers I agree oh my
god you're kidding me
guys please you know what this game is
also probably what it's like to be Brad
Pitt just constantly running after yeah
I bet Brad Pitt really likes I haven't
seen it getting a little greedy here
getting all agreed you don't want to get
trapped by old death or ooh
that's gonna come back right when I get
over here I guarantee it I knew it I
knew and I'm out of here
later later sucker play sorry Plagueis
pieces of trophy thank you game play
freeze oh my oh there we go
Weezer says I still haven't seen New
Hope's and no talking about all seven
movies I love it and I didn't order a
coffee 40 minutes ago
frozen like the girlfriends owned you oh
[ __ ]
she friendzone me a hard dude it was
rough it was rough
I know it's frozen but it's good I was
like super she could have been the one
man we didn't spend midnight Taylor for
a lot of reasons by then well no no
because she it's way too complicated but
she was like let's meet she's like let's
meet up after midnight are we are we
live again okay anyway so we met after
midnight it was oh man all right I think
we are we live okay we're live all right
sorry we're live sorry Beth I are just
going through some Dietzen yeah girl
details don't worry buddy ah so wait a
second here let's uh let's see we should
let's look at some of these relics here
so I'm gonna demon gargola fire for me
that could help burst of ice and versus
speed no no I don't care about gold
charm monster to fight for me who turns
me in any allies invisible mark and
random enemy then out of delay ah
whirlwind that could help maybe summons
dark demon gargoyle let's do the
gargoyle thing right yeah let's do it
team in effigy that's cool
black screen perfect jar-jar get it
dreams over oh I don't care about
different heads
oh yeah I'm just trying to I don't care
about my do we care about the Cape we
care about the game weapons ooh shield
throw I'm loving the shield throw weapon
to Billy a powerful Scooby howl Murtagh
ooh ooh this is kind of fun I should
have bought that alright we're gonna go
get the weapon and the lightning thing
SM all right
ready let's do it it's all my fault
that's right Weezer the Legion awaits
you oh well probably no armies are gonna
show no armies the a dental show up so
no biggie
NBD you know don't worry about it
everybody Beth are you want snapchat are
we snapchat pals why not open your heart
you know I like snapchat open your heart
to other things should I carry this
around maybe actually maybe I don't want
these to all blow up I'm gonna try okay
I'm gonna try blowing these rocks up is
that a good idea
all right nothing happened perfect
mm boom dead we can jump over here
before we do that though let's bust this
baby wide open I think this is breakable
feels like
Big Short is that a Martin Short tape
that'd be great
I would definitely look for the cracks
exactly I'm looking for the cracks
always thinkin of the cracks by the way
have you seen that guy I think it was on
reddit who posed with people's butt
cracks at a Magic the Gathering
tournament oh yeah
well that he got banned forever but I
guess just recently he got reinstated
for Magic the Gathering I can't jump
over the thing with that which makes me
happy
because I think now there's gonna be a
more butt crack pictures yeah and as
someone who isn't old whole life has
suffered but people see my butt crack I
can appreciate a good call-out can I use
potions what's the deal with the potion
situation we're back we're back rub OCD
says the Kezia the dungeon so last year
with this decor Weezer says yeah I did
so 2015 what it Beth what are you hoping
to get from 2016 okay fine what do you
hope we do achieve in 2016
besides a better attitude about my
grandma so far you failed what is this
weird thing here all right quite
understand that dudes we back the
potions oh the potions are the shield
toss ah Thank You Remy Remini or got it
don't missing a button yeah hahaha well
that's mine see CA ll be ACK these guys
are just so needy play with us come on
here we go
do you think Brad Pitt can leave his
house like without people following him
or do you think do you think you could
like put on a mask like beard and stuff
going you probably can't wreck it
people probably can't recognize ya but
he's been in movies now with he's been
in every his his face has been seen
every possible way probably not except
kissing my face yeah
love you bro 2016 the kiss Brad Pitt on
the mouth no I played loser and I was a
kid yeah it's the point of that game
it's like it's it's pretty old school
but it's and it was like you the way
they did age verification was they to
ask you these questions that only
someone that age would know I guess
getting real here
Jesus Christ that's pretty gnarly 2016
the year where nerds rule the internet
Catherine Erica Civil War Deadpool
Warcraft Assassin's Creed Suicide Squad
Wow
[Music]
oh I think that's it I think I'm dead
dead my dead dead retry what do I retry
from the beginning oh this ah back into
the KITT back into the hallway that I
might have to have you play with me
you just hit buttons it's really easy
use measure Leisure Suit Larry
verification questions about filling out
taxes and junk it's like about like I
remember one was about Joan Rivers I'm
not even kidding it was like it was just
like you yeah like you need to be 18 to
know about Joan Rivers like it was super
weird boom
don't gotcha
hey Germany what's up guten tag or just
tog if your uh you know for chill just
say tag tag like guten tag but just tag
you say yeah just having a tag just a
quick tug before I go to work watch it
watch your mouth stop it sorry no this
is too easy
I'm just tugging your chain and that's
that seems weird that I said that no one
came
20:16 and no coffee that's right no one
came to play and no one I gave someone
my credit card 2016 here's what I'm
gonna do in 2016 I'm going to master the
land this sea and the air how am I gonna
do that you ask I'm going to get a
boating license a motorcycle license and
a pilot's license Mike Kramer who works
for the show and you could see in the
behind the scenes Star Wars remote or he
has a couple good quotes video he has a
pilot's license so he's oh wow I killed
a lot of dudes there
he's uh he could fly a plane and he
doesn't he does it well or well enough
where he hasn't killed himself yet so
he's gonna give me some tips on flying
motorcycling I don't know I mean that's
how hard is it to ride motorcycle
boating now that could be a problem like
sailing I see I see not like a sailboat
I don't learn how to like tie knots and
stuff man the coolest captain's had of
course master space how everyone says
they're gonna do stuff but how do you
plan on doing it man you got to have a
plan where you Elon Musk cut to Elon
Musk is in the chat oh by the way they
landed that they landed that spaceship
it went up and then landed Falcon they
did it excuse me pardon me I'm gonna I'm
gonna have a new strategy in this game
that strategy is called run run away
no [ __ ] dad if only guys I need some
friends to help me with this game
you can't play single-person gauntlet
and you can't just sad which is what
this is GI Joe what are you talking
about Oh cuz he there the master of the
land no that guy is like the crappiest
little butter he's like it's like a nerf
bow and arrow it was a rocket not a
spaceship sorry captain quasar but by
the way if it went to space it is a
spaceship it's a ship that went to space
so you're wrong
oh Buckeye buck Irish 420 event under
rock for so long what ship we're in
Atlanta was the Falcon the whole thing
is they want to use space is really
expensive to go to space and it's so
expensive because I'll watch me just
joke these guys later y'all oh and I get
the to Turkey I'm gonna leave that gold
there it's not worth it
I'll get this gold see you fellas
and I can't come in geez
Oh F this is this is a little good for
old blade guys are fast too man
oh this is gonna be very bad in a second
Jesus Christ I just threw my shield at
the wall dude and I died for real uh
space is very expensive so the whole
thing is they want to create rockets
that can go up and then that are
reusable because then that will make it
about ten thousand times cheaper like an
ally see I don't think we've given up
we're just you know just take a little
break from space you know take a little
space break space break does that make
sense
I'm gonna quit to map cuz check this out
yeah that's right I've played in other
places so let's stop playing the same
thing let's go to the vacant scene
that's a word in a different words
together that's two words
space is awesome agree fart boy 120 I'm
guessing you're not an astronaut but
maybe fart boy 120 is an astronaut I
don't know I don't want to judge I don't
want to judge a chatter by their handle
but you know oh my god
Hey look at all those guys getting
killed by that big thing oh wow this is
Greg you just stand here and all these
guys are gonna get all chopped up do
this this is great
I do enjoy oh that guy's stuff goes
through I doing well I do enjoy a game
in which the bat oh and now they're
learning for their mistakes where the
bad guys have to deal with the same
stuff that I have to deal with you know
you can clean even playing field so to
speak just what was how we do down here
at the vacancy yeah but I don't think
you can be super tall to me oh come on
that's not cool yeah get some jerks
that's you it could be we don't know
anything about your life
we know nothing I mean well we know one
thing is what you're doing right now
which is watching the stream man this is
bogus
oh you mean NASA I'm sorry please
pronounce it correctly it's NASA I don't
understand what's happening here with
this beam situation oh that hurt me bad
yeah no [ __ ]
oh my god come on that's ridiculous
Wow Jesus Christ this is why I need
friends you can't kill me [ __ ]
I'm back Bobby's naked guys
I am NOT a fan of a lot of dudes this is
like a sausage party sausage party kill
this thing
let's see the opposite of thing hey kid
yeah this is like the full-si I'm trying
to take out the summoning stone thanks
Captain Obvious and eff this guy by the
way I sorry you were doing over there
and I'll appreciate it
give me some of them turkeys Jesus hey
look at this though hell is gold now is
this all just change that these guys all
drop because it didn't look like their
pants had like deep pockets so maybe you
know like when you're wearing pants that
don't have good pockets you like stuff
falls out all the time they were
happening no does that just mean these
delicious turkeys a lot of good protein
leave turkeys a good lean meat here we
go whoo there we go that was that was
the entire vacancy house the entire
vacant seat did it Wednes
Oh flame beacon says you like Bob so I
can check out the gate perception you
gained for former Bioshock readers to
form your new studio year or so ago oh
well thank you for that tip that's good
so far fifty-five minutes no coffee I
wonder if they're dead
I wonder if the intern is dead oh wait
Ramy horses you use the right joystick
use your shield to block I wish I knew
that no I do know knowing is half the
battle we're going to the Queen's
chambers ooh I hope we don't catch the
Queen unawares in her chambers in her
chambers perfect let's go to the Queen's
Chamber shall we
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what are the
weather like in LA it cold it's freezing
cold I am so cold right now I don't know
if really cold it's really cold normally
have a lot of body heat but cold in my
heart and my black cold black heart
especially there all right here we go
my cold black heart
what is this little thing you know again
the fashion accessories how come you can
only get a crown you can't get anything
cooler like you can't get like Yeezys or
like you know
oh this guy looks angry not my crown off
come on dude oh he lost his little
thingy oh good lord
come on man Oh
Oh nailed it I'm worried about
spiderwebs oh boy I didn't realize this
oh Jesus God yeah come on oh that's not
that's not fair
this apartment is a lot like my
apartment a lot of spiders gross stuff a
lot of dudes come out of my apartment so
many dudes so many males so many males
this is not alright new game new game
plan let's run away let's go so many
gross spiders my place is a filthy pit
of Filth
here's the problem I will say oh look at
this mr. bear do you think that I can
ever get girls in my apartment because
of all the male spiders and bugs now
here's the thing I I have crickets in my
apartment alright that's a problem for
some people not me like my sister for
instance you know they thinks it's
disgusting they sing to you at night
well I don't know name a number I would
some would say more than one cricket I
think more than one is probably well
it's 510
well what time of day I mean if you're
trying to sleep never get it right I
will say oh this is I'll tell you what
the worst is these guys why are they oh
that's just how I do in the old shape
Blair no girls allowed
Toronto I've tried friends
oh Jesus I will say one thing in 2016 I
quit actually I quit all the those
dating services everything I'm off
everything this is not fair I'm unhappy
about that's right
maybe 20 keep it clean in 2016 maybe
guys this is the year that I try to
clean up my part yeah I just feel bad
though like what do you do well duh if
your ask someone to come clean your
party you pay someone to come clean your
apartment I've asked many people no one
will come around to clean up from it
these are the clean your apartment what
do you do then while you're while
they're cleaning you just sit there I
think it's super weird I'm like look
part of me has a crappy dirty apartment
because I won't pay someone to come
because I feel bad all right guard do
myself that's true although that seems
like a lot of work isn't it boom what
wait how many crickets you of your
apartment huh the pot calling the kettle
bit black here alright fair enough
crickets aren't bad just hop around I am
more a human stink bug for my own
apartment you know artists a stink bug
in a roach aren't those the same thing
not that I'm judging you
sorry I'm fighting a billion people
Brown memorial rated stink bug got it
they like to lurk Oh
Jesus Christ death will by the way stop
me from having my vengeance that's
exactly what'll stop me because if
people keep killing me I'm not gonna
have my vengeance
these guys are the Roy the roided-out
dudes are problem man see this is the
you need somebody to watch your back in
gauntlet you know one person takes the
tower the other person takes the bad
guys otherwise they just all kind of get
on you you know wait is maybe I should
take these explosives somewhere and blow
something up that's too busy reading
Star Wars things
oh my god now you're so
maybe I should wait maybe I should that
should be a selling point maybe I need
to run at the wave when I talk to girls
at bars maybe I say hey look I hope the
apartment you know maybe that's the kind
of person why should I pretend to be
somebody I'm not
yeah you know maybe they should write
like I'm a real outdoorsy person I mean
I do like the outdoors I really you know
what 2016 no [ __ ] I actually do want
to go camping is a big thing I haven't
done that what do you mean like I just
want to get a tent and go camping wait
oh there are different levels of
campaign maybe like there's like a
that's not camping - camping is like
you're out in the woods you have a tent
I don't do this like Kim Kardashian
let's go camping at the Marriott yeah
yeah what is it
glamping glamping glamping okay that's
the worst thing I've ever heard in my
life
I basically camp with the amount of bugs
that are in my apartment I basically
camped 24/7 that's as real as it gets
oh this is a issue all right run away
run away new strategy run away let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
caffeine is no good I'm not giving that
anything that deserves nothing and
deserves nothing there's so many bad
guys
stop saying that you're just taunting
them when you say nothing I say now
let's see look that's what happened they
say I say nothing will stand in my way
then they're like oh really pop pop pop
yeah what the [ __ ] oh great now kill the
food perfect I'm just this is pur this
is oh there's another thing over here
great great great super happy about this
up what are them what's the black thing
again let me just block these dudes
promise these guys are real jerks you
know what a problem is with a lot of
these guys in this game they don't
understand
personal space you know like I need like
out like a like a six inch at least like
a buffer you know you can't just roll up
on somebody like this like I'm Jude czar
smelling me I'm smelling them it's all
well they're touching each other I hate
human contact that's bad I don't like
people touching me yeah just crickets I
only enjoy crickets touching me only if
you're a cricket you can touch me wow
that was terrible yeah oh you think
thanks oh that guy sucks oh my god who
is that saying that to me
well there we go deader than dead I got
the award for deader than dead that's
Jesus right oh my god oh yes is the
coffee oh thank you so much thanks thank
you you're the best you want to say hi
camera you have a great scar [ __ ] just
wave hi there
chief for god sakes just wave hi Jesus
no kid oh my god
trying to steal the limelight from all
play oh oh god damn it
maybe this is a sign that I've drank too
much coffee 2016 you guys is often I'm
sorry thank you for the coffee I spill
it again what's going on in here this is
a messed up Cup oh my god sorry this is
the worst day of my life 2016 worst
Monday melee ever pretty good yeah
PlayStation network's down everything's
okay and there anymore ah mold on the
carpet I'm sorry I'm sorry there's more
ice oh my straws don't look like mold
I don't know I'm Jesus I got friends up
by my own coffee yeah exactly that's you
know 2016 is gonna be the year of making
friends I think I'm gonna take that
negative a turn to a positive
now I've got friends I mean the girl
father where still she's awesome
so I I hope I can still be your friend I
hope I open this can here's what I hope
hope in this case the friendzone doesn't
mean or a fast feet
because normally friendzone means don't
ever talk to me right I'll run in to
your tea market nothing weird yeah
exactly exactly that's not in every
experience so it makes me sad but I will
say hopefully that's not you know what
2016 gonna have a my outlook is clean
I'm trying to put Rhys the 2016 go oh
there we go 2016 things are gonna gleam
I'm gonna say hopefully me and this girl
could still be friends it'll be great
unlike me and this coffee which is so
pissed okay well I guess they call this
you know when they leave room there you
go we got it okay there we go all right
guys and now for more gauntlet whoo that
was atrocious 2016 year the crickets no
that's been every other year of my life
Oh spleen 2016 maybe just be nicer to
your spleen
2016 be kind your spleen I think it's
just full of bile
I think the spleen is just up you know
I'm gonna do this let's play smarter
this is probably what I'm supposed to do
the whole time but I wasn't paying
attention you know what this coffee kind
of sobered me up [ __ ] that guy
ooh
oh that guy also destroys Charlie
Kaufman I saw him on the lot the other
day by the way yeah he was over by
Starbucks yeah okay well you guys really
you guys don't care about anybody you
care about charlie copy he's yeah I was
great he had a huge beard
[Music]
I don't know is that you I still gotta
see Schenectady or whatever it's
supposed to be good right geez Wow we
certainly took a turn I don't Charlie
Kaufman yeah it sucks don't see it then
I guess then I got ya over the coffee oh
yeah yeah
the answer is uh I should be fired
[Music]
laptop lady what's that oh that's my
subreddit god this is like terrible like
how Brad Pitt look uh how Brad pitting
I'm I'm getting so Brad pity right now
you guys Oh boom yeah oh that was great
great moves great moves all right here's
the problem that guy is a real [ __ ]
how do I make ooh he'll kill those guys
for me though keep them in the circle
the circle of trust
/ circle of death all right now it's
just you and me buddy hey I got a
present for you here you go yeah stop
saying that man that's the voice of
Captain C in the circle is there wait by
the way a mouse for future streams we
can just get the Benny Hill theme going
on yeah
kill me but it's gotta be wait a second
what the hell is this thing I just made
Joe hey I could do it the whole time
little dragon man oh wow wow look at
this looks like the tables have turned
mofos hey I can't make that thing
anymore though it kind of sucks oh this
is gonna be real bad I can just sense it
now meanwhile me
you can just screencap this like
meanwhile 8 p.m. and blurts apartment he
does yeah have your thing of Guy Fieri
that's diners drive-ins Adam Savage yes
or Jamie whatever his face is that isn't
that show end come on don't throw that
frickin shield at the other thing man
how do i oh let's slice through a number
of these little things that's a grand
love Mythbusters Oh God half man come on
all these little jumping spiders are the
worst by the way spiders that jump any
any bug that jump scares the crap out of
me kill this little guy all right we
just got the big spider left Oh Oh God
oh Jesus Oh
Jebus now that yeah I did that once but
I think I'm out of the r-1 juice come on
Oh got him yeah I was just saying I hate
hopping things what's the scariest bug
our snakes a bug because I think snakes
are the scariest snakes are more of a
reptile okay there we go I got some
turkey I think part of what makes bugs
scary are the size science who said that
was great it smells so much like coffee
right I'm sitting literally in a puddle
of coffee it's not a joke
yo you got yuca pin killing it
tapeworms scary tell tipper grovel all
right
how are we gonna do this this is gonna
be really bad
that's not true that's the bigger they
are the harder that's not true at all
sometimes big things fall light is a
what if it's a giant feather that's big
but it falls very softly you know what
I'm saying Jesus Christ figure there are
the harder they fall as they've done
this phrase I've ever heard what if the
crown get me does that get me something
cool oh wait let's make the thing make
the thing kill him kill him see look at
this would be so much easier if I had a
pal oh my god this game would be so much
easier if I had one friend just one
friend it's all I need no friends
God quit jinxing it Valkyrie shut up
just you know what you ever heard of
like a sore winner
that's it Valkyrie is just a sore winner
she's like you know I'm the best that
immediately does yeah shut up
just be cool but you know what just be
chill when you get a win just be cool
about it
oh yeah it's captain shade throw it to
more shade at me oh yeah how do you feel
about that
what about to some of this yeah hey I
know you get up here look at all this
gold up here how do we get up there
do oh man I got a but a giant cat would
fall very gracefully that's true doom
shine exactly see the bigger they are
the harder they fall is that's [ __ ]
don't say that oh cool I got a crown I
got a dope crown right now how do I get
up oh come on you know somebody should
really get into these I need like an
advance team to like get in here and
like really softened oh geez this is guy
look bigger or is he just closer see
bigger than the other dudes are easy
just closer I can't tell oh no my crown
got knocked way up there am I supposed
to get that crown back dude Oh [ __ ]
filled my [ __ ] crown there's Burger
King so how does this work
yeah I wish I bought some friends how
about that if I had a friend in this
game I would beat it already probably I
tell you one thing oh Jesus Christ
I am running from the spa good spiders
not anymore
Oh God are these spiders yeah come on
come on let's go let's go let's go let's
go let's go I've been poisoned let's go
I'm running I'm running I'm running I'm
running I'm running let's run let's run
let's run how do I get the where'd I get
the key where do I get the key how do I
get all I'm trapped and I'm dead trapped
in dead
you keep incest you really need a crown
underground with all these horrible
nightmare creatures we gotta look
fabulous you know it's like RuPaul man
you just want to look fabulous no matter
what you're doing whether you're killing
monsters whatever you're doing you want
to look fabu it's important Sode RuPaul
by the way one time San Francisco he
looked amazing join his white coat
awesome let's go we're back the bigger
they are the softer they fall mofos
let's do it the bigger they are the more
graceful they are when they dance now
that's a that's actually true did you
hear that thing that Chris Farley like
took ballet lessons that he actually
like knew how to ballet dance
nobody puts play in the corner except
aggressively diet barbarian uh the only
person who puts play in the corners bleh
I will say with everything I destroy
everything everything I touch I ruined
that's true that's the thing is I don't
think like here's the thing the girl
near Z I friendzone myself she didn't
she was basically just telling me what I
had already done to myself you know what
I'm saying that's the thing it didn't
come out of nowhere I did that to myself
I screwed it up like I do have it so
really she did she even exist maybe it
was like a Tyler Durden situation and
she was me and if you looked at if
there's a webcam yeah if there's a
webcam maybe it would just be me in a
wig talking to myself like in psycho you
know yeah in my apartment by myself a
cricket who knows there's no maybe it
was a cricket maybe it's the queen of
the cricket good event I was really sick
over break so maybe that it was all a
dream I used to read Word Up Magazine
you know like biggie said like biggie
said Weezer says I used to dress in
ballet outfits just for the fun of it
okay oh here we go
well this is interesting okay now wait a
second I don't want to open all these
things let's figure out a way through
here I open this kill these dudes this
actually is kind of cool because this is
I remember this exact kind of level from
the original gauntlet which is really
fun all right what do we want to fight
here the spider is probably the easiest
right these guys are gonna suck if we go
here we get two keys so we'll go here we
get those keys and of course now they're
spiders I knew it I knew it did you say
oh they jump
there we go just corn room boom alright
here we go
alright now let's go after this one
right kill this spider what do you think
let's do it oh and all these other see
it's tough it's not as advertised I'm
not a fan I'm gonna get away because I
think I don't want to be oh wow I just
got pwned as the kids say I would offer
up my sister to the blade gods if she's
had a boyfriend
look I don't waste good people on me
I'll just ruin it ruin everything right
yeah don'ts for God's sakes you want
someone to be happy don't introduce them
to me because I'm the worst all right
here we go
[Music]
nervous whoa they're aliens except David
Boies did that could be cool ah the
Crown's back give me that crown give me
that crown
whoops I don't want to touch gotta be
careful man don't want to touch the
other stuff oh that's so many dudes so
many dudes let's get out of here
let's run run away run away I'm a pretty
princess with a sweet crowd there we go
baby here we go
latest sucka I'll take this I'll take
this I'll take this I'll take this Wow
well you certainly are persistent fellow
I'll give you that really coming after
me eh
what about this stuff what if I jump
over here loses interest immediately and
he's back
is he back he's back a little pal hey
friend I guess I gotta fight you huh
ow no peanuts oh [ __ ] you I'm so you a
ho I can't believe you made knock Mike I
was looking fabulous I'm all glamping
over here take it
I donno what this does what movie let's
push it off this thing I don't know what
it does but it seems like it's fun
interact oh I see you got to do this
thing here comes a spider oh [ __ ]
where's the worst man that's playing
harder yeah yeah trust me I've never
played hard to get in my life I mean
hard to get maybe like hard to
understand hard to comprehend is more my
style hey there guys just I wish I had
like big old boots I gotta stomp on
these dumb spiders
although spiders I think in real life
really help you out you know because I
know there's a right now there's an epic
battle going on in my bathroom between
two spiders who've set up these webs and
then all these crickets who they trap
it's kind of a cool it's like Lord of
the Rings every time I go to the
bathroom I kind of check in on him you
know which of the orcs well I consider
the crickets the pests so I consider the
spiders the good guys you know because
they're like killing you they're like
the fellowship right the fellowship of
this spiders basically is what's going
on in my place yeah you're right
it's art because Tolkien like truly if
you go read Tolkien not to get serious
for a second but he created so much
crazy stuff it's oh it's hard to not rip
him off because he's did everything like
you're just like Jesus oh look at all
this delicious turkey just like Zankou
oh my god would you think thank you I
don't do the girl I'm gonna do the
sauces I don't play that game it's so
succulent and juicy guys in LA there's
this place called Zankou chicken it's
also a back song what Hey look I can
stomp on all these little eggs wait you
mean the Zankou murders yeah no [ __ ]
I don't like getting trapped oh no a
bigger spider you come on man wait time
to hit the our old friend The Gargoyle
what's happening
get him gargoyle oh Jesus
I've almost got her let's kill her
yeah oh there but then I died but I
killed her though killed her ass if only
there was a cricket queen that I could
make Mike Oh see now this isn't cool
get up gargoyle get him gargy that's
like all my gargoyle gargy well I think
that'll do it Oh dead I think that'll do
it for today guys thank you for watching
the first Monday May of 2016 we learned
a lot we learned a lot coffee is spilled
hearts are broken snapchats were viewed
a great Jordan snapchat ah thank you
guys for joining us we'll see you guys
next week I don't know I think so
anybody functional exactly we got hey
Albert shock ah but yes hopefully
PlayStation will work and maybe we can
play a game with you guys thank you guys
for joining us and as always tune in to
twitch that TV slash Erin Blair later on
the week I'll be playing on my own
channel cuz you know it's just mean the
crickets yes let's do it alright see you
guys later have a great week Happy New
Year
you